水は？ぶつからないんです
通っていっちゃうんです
そういうことで その粗識細識の区別が出てくるんです
だから まあ彩色はいいんだけど
あまりにも細かくなるとまたわからなくなっちゃうんです
音にしたっても 音は聞こえるぐらいはもういいんだ
あるんだけど どんどんどんどん細かくなっていくと聞こえない
あまりにも細かすぎて
色も同じなんで 目に見えるものも同じなんですね
我々の目よりは彩色なんですけど
見えてるんです そこで目に入る情報はどんどん細かくなってきちゃうと
見えなくなっちゃうんです
で あのザルで まあいろんなものをうどんでもラーメンでもね
ザルに入れても大丈夫でしょうし
それで でもザルにはいろいろきめ細かい穴があるんですね
うどんでもラーメンでも豆でもザルに米でも入れられますけど
じゃあ水入れちゃったらどうなるんですかと
あまりにも細かいんだから
ざっと抜けていっちゃうんですね
で ものをこす場合は 我々その法則を使ってるんですね
まあそういうことでですね
まあそれぐらいで結構だとは思いますけど
近色というのは何ですかと
近っていうのはやっぱり近い色と
で 今言った十十二種類なんですね
近色っていうのは 近いっていうのは
目は自分の いわゆる自分という立場から見れば自分の目ですから
見えるものは遠いものであって
聞こえる音は外であって
聞く耳がここにこちらにあるんだと
そういうことで近色と遠色と分けてるんです
そこで疎対色っていうのは何ですかというと
この今の言った十二種類を疎対色というんです
疎対色っていうのは どうもお互いにぶつかるということなんです
対立するんです 例えば目
目には光の色がどうもぶつかっちゃうんですね
対立する だから見える
耳に音という物質はどうしてもぶつかってしまって
もう反応しちゃう 反応すること
対立なんです 反応しなきゃ別に
例えば何か我々薬を飲んだと
何の反応もないならば
その薬はもうただ水飲んだことと同じなんですね
何の反応もないんだけど
でも水飲んだってのも反応あるでしょ
体には 大体病気になったところで
なんと薬飲んだんだけど効き目はないっていうのは
我々は病気の症状に反応を欲しがったんですね
その反応を出してくれなかったならば
その薬は効きませんと
という風に言っちゃうんです
だからこの反応ですね
対立っていうのは だから目は光に反応して
耳は音に反応してという風に
体は色という三種類の音
色に反応する そういう風に反応するんだから対立色というし
他のものには対立色と言わない
無対色と言うんです そこでこの魂論やら我論やら
もう宗教で哲学も全てここら辺で生まれるんです
眼耳鼻舌身と色声香味触というところから
それから生色ですね ダン
ダンシキと何とか何とかいう
イッティ・バールゥ プリティ・バールーパという
この性別する色二つと
それから名色 それぐらいなんです
他の色っていうのはもう全然もう関係もない
考えてもない それだけに基づいて
この全ての世界 人間の妄想の世界を創っているんです
神様はいるかいないか
人間は初めはどうやって生まれたんですか？どこから生まれてどこまで行くんですかとか
どうだとか ありとあらゆることはこの色の世界から生まれてくるものです
妄想に過ぎない なんでみんなこの我々の哲学妄想だ
もうただの妄想やと言わないんですかね
何かそれでもあるでしょうと
そんな偉大なる 何でしたっけ
天才 天才たちがくだらない嘘を言うわけないでしょうと
信じ込んじゃいますけど
結局むしろ嘘をついてるわけじゃないんだけど
くだらない妄想をやること確かなんです
別にわざわざ嘘をついてるわけじゃないんだから
自分の妄想を言ってるだけだから
本人は自分が作った妄想を人に言ってるだけ
だから嘘じゃないんです
この言ってるものはその通りであると思う我々はちょっとおかしいと
なんで哲学やら世の中の宗教やら
もうただの妄想ではないかと我々思えないんですかというと
この妄想の何性というんですか
この あるいはこの 似ているんですね
似ている性質 私がする妄想と他の人する妄想と
この表現してみれば何とか似ているんです
似ているんだから やっぱり本当だと
例えばある人は何かどこかの店に行ってケーキ食べたんだと
それすごく美味しかったと
ああそうですかと言って
自分もその店に行ってケーキを食べる
それで自分も何か味を味わう
そうすると ああ やっぱりあの店のケーキは美味しいですよと
言ったら番目の人も ああ
やっぱりそういえばあれ嘘ではないんだと
あの店のケーキはまあ嘘で
美味しいでしょうでも決めてしまっちゃうんです
経験似てるんだから この
例えばこの人間は神様に作られたということは
どんな文化でも言ってることなんですね
だから真実やと 真実ですという人々がいるんです
なぜならば どんな文化を見ても
どんな巨大文明を見ても
神という概念があるでしょうに
ということは 科学的な考え方を見れば
どんな人でも同じものを想像するならば
同じ結果だから やっぱり正しいですよとするしか余裕がなくなっちゃうんです
だから正しいんじゃなくて
妄想は似てるっていうことなんです
妄想は似ている でも一つは目があって
そこから物事を見て 耳があって
音を聞いて それからいろんなことを考えて感じて
そこで実感が生まれてきて
その実感に基づいて この実感はどこから生まれたかと考えるだけであって
ですから哲学はもう東洋哲学も西洋哲学もそれほど差がないんです
考え方は同じなんです
東洋思想 西洋思想という
すごい区別できるものじゃないんですよ
同じものを考えてるんです
ただの言葉違うだけ 東洋人の文化と言葉は違うし
西洋人の文化と言葉は違うんですからね
いわゆる動詞は先に入れるか後に入れるかということによって感じが違うんです
日本語みたいに動詞が最後に来ると
やっぱり名詞 いわゆる動ではなくて止でストップですか
止まってるような哲学が生まれてくるんです
アーリア言語の世界では動詞が中心でしょ
ですから 動的 動のダイナミックな哲学が生まれるんです
中国系の哲学はダイナミクスじゃないんです
ステティックなんです
それだけ ステティックといっても物事は変化するんだから
そこはもう否定することはできないんですね
そこでヨーロッパの場合
やっぱりダイナミズムで生まれますけど
やっぱりでも理解する場合は固定して理解してしまっちゃう
認識は 人間には認識 あるものしか認識できないんです
ものはあるとしか認識できない
ですから ヨーロッパ人もダイナミズムの中からこのステティック状態を探しているんです
中国の文化ではステティック状態からダイナミック状態を探しているんです
ただそれだけ その差だけ
言ってることは同じ 同じくただの妄想
何の何のこともないんです
それは仏教の立場から見れば
他の立場から見ればじゃないんです
ですから 我々のこの いろんな人の思想は似ているんだから
この その似ているという
俺ら特別な言葉がなければちょっと言いにくいんだけどね
そこを持ちましてもう捨てられなくなってるんです
先生 妄想の類似性は証明していいですか
うんうん 妄想の類似性です
一応そういう言葉でも覚えておきましょう
特にこのインド文化のね
このいろんな宗教がありまして
そこでよく見えるんですね
この類似性は いろんな宗派がありますけど
いろんな酔い寝る方やら瞑想の仕方やらいっぱいあるんだけど
結局見ると全部似てるんですね
それは妄想の類似性なんです
じゃあ難しい話はやめて
ウパーディンナ・ルーパ
アヌパーディンナ・ルーパ
二重一番目 カムジャン・ウパーディンナ・ルーパ
イタラン・アヌパーディンナ・ルーパ
あんまりちょっとこちらはどうしましょうかね
そこでこのウパーディンナって日本語でね
執着 その言葉大事なんですね
集中っていう漢字で意味が取れるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
我がものだと いわゆるとらわれている
私のものだというふうに
この実感が作る色とそうでない色ということなんですね
いわゆる執着 執着することになる色と執着することにならない色と二つに分ける
そこで執着することになる色は十八種類あるんです
それはなぜ 何ですか 何ですかと
今でなくても後からわかります
そこでわかりやすく言えば
この色の生まれが後から説明します
色は この物質的なエネルギーはなぜ生まれるかと
一つはこの心のエネルギーで生まれるんです
我々心というエネルギーを持ってますから
その心というエネルギーで物質は生まれるんです
それだけあれば大変ありがたい話ですけど
そうすると自分の心で何か希望すれば
その物質は生まれますから
で なかなかそれだけじゃないんですね
次にこの 物質は物質を生み出しちゃうんですね
それはよくわかるんですね
皆様誰でも 物質は物質をもっていることを知ってるんだから
そこだけ知ってるんだから
みんな頑張ってこの世界を作ってるんです
物質をもって新しい物質を作る
例えばお腹が空いたらご飯食べたい
そうするとご飯はもう空間から生まれるわけじゃないんです
物質から生まれるんです
そこで種を持っていて
ちゃんと畑を作って 水を入れて
それを植えて ちゃんと面倒を見てあげて
肥料をあげて もうちょうどいい時期にそれを刈りて
それからまあ米にして炊いて食べると
そこで何もないところにご飯が生まれたんだけど
やっぱり物質から生まれたんです
すべての物質はそこで
あるいはいろんな形で集めたんだから
人のエネルギーやら太陽エネルギーやら水やらいろんなもの
ですが そこは我々知ってるんです
物質から物質が生まれるんだと
ですから 人間がいろんな新しいものを作る
新しいものを作ったとしても
別に元々はあった物質のちょっとした変化なんですね
ほとんど知らないのは心から物質が生まれることなんです
心からも生まれるんです
ですから この 我々この物質の世界に入れている
この強調性というか ものすごい大事にしているでしょ
物質の世界 全ては物質世界にしているんだから
大変なんです 例えばこの最近
この中国がこのミサイル発射したということで
もう今 NHK でももう再放送流れてますけど
もう 1時半ぐらいで 夜で
どれくらいこのアメリカが日本も巻き込まれてもう戦争準備なんですね
単なる中国人がふざけてると思う
どうか分かりませんだけどね
そこで台湾は去年でしたね
台湾はもう大変な状態で緊張状態でどうでもいいことでも
ただミサイルだってそんなもん発射してみなさい
別に爆弾を投げてくるわけじゃないし
それに僕はあれを見て
どれほどお金 中国人にとってはもうミサイル 3発ぐらい発射して実験することだけだからお金かかりません
そんなに それでアメリカの空母やらいろんな船やらもう行ってもう感知して探したり
それで日本の飛行機なんか自衛隊は全部ずっと 24時間体制で情報を集めていて
膨大なお金でしょうね
あれ 何のため？何も結果もなく
そこであの 3発終わったら
それでみんな帰るんです
中国人もちょうど台湾の戦況の時はそれちゃんとやめていたんです
もう余計にね 刺激させてはいけないんだから
それ見て私は考えてな
人間っていうのはただ物質のために生きている物質の奴隷みたいなもんなんです
もしちょっとでも中国が乱暴なことをしたならば
もう何万人でも死んじゃっても平気で
もう戦争で戦争の準備しよう
そこでアメリカはどうせ戦争に出ませんから
もう他の国をとにかく巻き込めてあげようと思って
日本にいちいちいちいち言ってるんですね
あんた方はこれやりなさい
あれやりなさいと ただアメリカから守ってもらうだけにはいけませんと
あんた方も何かしなくちゃいけない
あれはもう まあそれは表である
でも日本も巻き込まれて
それで日本人が戦争しているんだから
しょうがなく手伝ってますよとアメリカ側に言っているんでしょうと思いますけど
まあ日本もやっぱりいろいろ問題があって
そんな簡単に巻き込まれることはできないし
で まあそれはそれで 私たちはここで勉強したい
勉強してほしいのは この物質の入れてるこのどれほど大事だと思っているかということなんですね
ですから このそこまで全てのエネルギー
物質のために絞っているんだから
これくらいの物質世界が生まれてるんですね
でもこれはそんな大したことがないんです
今の物質文明っていうのは
まあすぐ壊れるんです
我々どれほど頭絞って建物作ったっても
まあ年 年ぐらい放っておけばどうなるんですかと
もう全部ボロボロ壊れてしまいますから
何のことなく 例えばいきなり地球の環境が変化しちゃったらどうなるんですかね
全部終わるでしょ ですから
これほど力強く もうお金使って物質
物質 物質と思っても まあ 1 日で壊れるものなんです
作っているのは そこは物質が物質を生まれる
物質が物質を作るという部分
で 私たちは心が物質を作っているんだよと言っているんです
もしあれぐらい力 心を成長するために作ったならば
また同じ世界が生まれるんです
もしある文明の人々が心は大事ですよと
物は大事じゃないんだと
思って心成長してみようと思うと
心に必要な物質を心から作ることはできるようになっちゃうんです
そうするとそれなりの文化が生まれるんです
手で物を作る文化ではなくて
心で物を作る文化 で その時生まれる物質文化はまた違いますけどね
そういう文明も昔はあったでしょうと思いますけどね
あったんです 微かな記録はあるんです
今 神話としてしか残ってないんだけど
そんなことまあなかなか簡単には言いにくいんだけど
で 例えばこの ある時期で人々は空を飛んでいたんだと
言った途端 現代の人々はニコッと笑っちゃうんですね
もしかすると昔は生命は鳥みたいな状態でいたんだからね
そういう風に言うならば
進化する前に空を飛んでいたんですよというならば
もうなんとかそんな話じゃないんです
進化する前に空を飛んでいたのは飛んでいたんで
それは人間じゃないんだから
こちらに来たら人間が飛んでいたということなんです
そういう時期もありました
それは心の文明の時期であって
人間が移動したい場合は
まあそういう風に心のエネルギーで移動する
ですから 飛行機は要らなくなっちゃう
飛行機は手で作るものだから
物質で物質作る世界だから
だから心を大事に考える文明では
そういう飛行機も車もない
その代わりに食べ物も違う
農業はしない ですから不思議な文明なんです
農業は全くしませんだけど
ちゃんと食べている ちゃんと栄養取っている
という文明も 現れあった時期があったそうで
今の地球っていうのは物質文明ですね
で 心は物質作る 物質が物質作る
それから大体まあその 2つで考えましょう
カンマチットとアハラという 2つ
4つありますけど  2つで考えておいて
そこでもう一つ物質作るのはカルマなんですね
カルマっていうのは業
業っていうのは心を持ってる
心を持ってるもう一つのエネルギーなんです
それはもうポテンシャルという言葉ありますね
と同じで ポテンシャル
心のポテンシャルだと思った方が分かりやすいと思いますね
ポテンシャルというのは
まあなんか変な えっ 潜在的なことで
まあ別になんでしょうかね
あれは 例えばこの時計は
このこちらで机の上にあると
机に机の上から床に落ちると
そうすると時計の中にエネルギーがあるんですね
ですから もしかすると床に落ちて壊れるかもしれません
だって壊れないかもしれません
そこで同じ時計は 私はこの天井に置いておく
そこで天井から落ちると
天井から落ちると時計が必ず壊れる
机の上から落ちても壊れないんですね
同じ時計なのに やっぱり天井のぐらいの高さにあると
ポテンシャルとしてエネルギーが高いんです
別に時計自体変化したわけじゃないんです
あまりにもエネルギー高まっても
時間はどんどん早く進んでいるんですよとか
そんなことはないんです
そういう物質の 物質の説明ですけど
同じ石でしたっても  10g ぐらいの石がまあ体にぶつかっても何のこともないんだけど
でも 1KM ぐらい遠くから落ちてきちゃったら
もう怪我して大怪我するかもしれません
死ぬかもしれません 人は
その場合  1KM ぐらい遠くある石にはポテンシャルとしてエネルギーあるんです
でも石はそのまんまなんです
それで心にはそのポテンシャルというエネルギーがあるんですね
それはカルマと呼ぶんです
カルマ 業と呼ぶんですね
それから物質作られるんです
で この我々はものすごく自分という風な
この区別するのは このカルマから生まれる物質なんです
業から生まれる物質がありまして
そのその心のポテンシャル
エネルギー ポテンシャル違うでしょ
各人がみんな心を持っています
心みんな同じなんですけど
ポテンシャルが違うんです
例えば私の持っている心
皆さん持っている心同じですが
私の育ち方が違うし 育った環境は違うし
教育は違うし 生き方は違うし
ですから 私の心持っているポテンシャルと皆様の心持っているポテンシャルが違うんです
そこで生まれる時でも同じことなんです
同じ家族で兄弟で生まれても
そのその心持っているポテンシャルが違う
違うんですね そこで個人差っていうものが生まれてくるんです
ある人は私は寒いのは嫌いですよと
私は暑いのは嫌いですよと
私は肉は嫌いで魚は大好きですよと
私は肉も魚も嫌いで野菜だけですよと言ってる人々
いろいろ個別差が出てきて
怒りっぽい人やら いつでもニコニコとしている人やら
頭のいい人やら悪い人やら
音楽好きな人と科学好きな人とか
いろんなものが出てきて
我々このアイデンティティアイデンティティと偉そうに言ってるのは
この業から生まれる識なんです
業から生まれる物質なんです
あの走る人がカールルイスですか
日本で人気ある人 で カールルイスってのはそんなに足が速かったわけじゃないんですね
ある日突然ものすごく足が速くなっちゃったんですね
それでね 彼が彼にはそういう恵みというんですか
突然 もうそういう恵みがあって
世界一流の世界一の選手になったと
というふうに偉そうに思っているんですね
だからもうどうしても神様っていうのはもう全然存在しませんよ状態じゃなくて
やっぱり確実に存在してるんだと
そう思っちゃうんですね
自分にはもうもう生まれつき素晴らしい声がついてるんだと
ですからもう幸福になってるんだと
やっぱりもう恵み 恵まれてるとよくなんとかという言葉使ってますけど
そういうふうな人々はいて
音楽の才能ある人がいて
絵の才能ある人がいてと
そこで自分がやっぱりもう例えばこの何て言いますか
このあのローマの教会に絵描いた人
何でしたっけ な 自分ボケてます
忘れ アンジェロ ミカエルアンジェロとかね
その人が絵を描くと なんとなくこのまあ描かれたんだというふうな感じで一人作ってるんですね
自分で描いたというよりは
描かせたんだという感じで
で だからそういうふうな
まあ素晴らしいあだこととかね
まあ別に絵は素晴らしいかもしれませんだけど
まあそこで言いたがってるんですね
神様がミカエルアンジェロに乗っ取って乗り移って
まあ立派な絵を描く そう考えるとバカバカらしいんで
神もよくバカではないかと
なんでそんなに絵を描いて欲しがってるんですか？と
教会で人間描く絵だからね
神のことじゃないんだから
だからまあとにかくそこは分かってないだけなんですね
みんな それ自分の業から生まれる識によって体が変化するんです
そこでカールルイスは走れるは
マイケルジャクソンは踊れるは
ミカエルアンジェロは絵を描けるは
ベートーヴェンは音楽を作るは
それだけのことで それで音楽は作りたいんだけど
なかなか耳も聞こえなくなったとかね
まあという まあそれもやっぱりその業の識なんですね
それ生まれちゃったらもうどうしようもないんで
それは自分なんです そこはもう何でも間違って使うのは人間のやり方だから
この業論をあなたの業ですよ
あなたの業ですよとか
偉そうに全然わかってなく
一般の社会で使ってますけど
僕はそれにはもうやめてほしいというかね
いい加減勝手に業 業だと言うなと
だから例えば私はいろんなものをもう批判するでしょ
今も富士山の信仰 笑っちゃったんだけど
でもちゃんと理解しないで
いい加減なそういうことを言ってはいけないんですね
我々のアイデンティティ
我々の才能 我々の区別
業識から 業識から生まれるんです
自我が生まれる  自我っていうのはないんだけど
自我という概念が生まれる
それに自我というだけのことで
ただこの体に ですから
それは業から生まれるんだ
それも業のポテンシャルが変わると
それも変わってしまっちゃう
絵を描ける人は絵を描けなくなる場合もあるし
音楽で一生やっていた人は
ある日音楽を全く嫌いになっちゃって
もう農業やろうと思う時もあるし
大きな会社 仕事で人は全部辞めて山に入って自然の中で生きているということもやっているし
ですから それはポテンシャルだから変わっちゃうんですね
そこでも永遠な自我というものはあるわけじゃないんですね
その永遠の自我というものはないんだから
ないということを理解するために
もうこの分析してあって
この何でしたっけ このカルマから生まれる色業から生まれる色にウパーディンナルーパというんです
執着に何とか色ですね
執着色というんです 難しいんだけど
そこら辺 この何でしたっけ
この まあこれはもう瞑想の体験から理解するしか方法ないんです
で 前と同じ話になるかもしれませんけど
瞑想してわかってないんですから
あなたの瞑想はまだ足りませんということも言えますけど
やっぱりこの場合はしっかり瞑想するとこういうことしか発見しないんです
事実ですから 例えば瞑想すると
自分が何に囚われているかと
この体の中でわかるんです
例えば瞑想したところですぐ悟ってしまっちゃいますか？誰かが
私は瞑想しました はい
悟りましたと そんなことないんです
悟らないところが一番大事なところなんです
悟るところじゃないんです
なぜか なぜ悟らないんですか
何かに引っかかっているんです
何かに未練があるんです
じゃあそれ何ですか？と
見てください ですから
もう悟っちゃったらもうおしまいだから
それで悟らないのは大変大事なポイントで
そこで智慧が生まれるんです
で 何かに引っかかっている
それは自我というところで
自我って何ですか？というと
まあ何のことない くだらないものに
くだらないものに自分が引っかかっているんだと
子供に引っかかっているわ
仕事に引っかかっているわ
体の病気に引っかかっている
いろんなもうそういう見ると
それ全てカルマから生まれるものなんです
例えば 私に家族がありまして
子供がいて旦那がいるんだから
そんな真剣に瞑想なんかはできっこはないんですって言うとかね
言ってやらないと なぜやらないかと自分で聞いてみればいいんです
やらないのは 私には朝は朝ごはん作ることがあって
昼は昼飯を作ることであって
夜はごはんを作る仕事があるんだと
だから瞑想する暇がないんだと
いわゆる心も分かりやすく言えば
心清らかにすることよりは
三食作ることは大事ですよと
ある人に私はお寺にたまにでも来たらどうですかと聞いたんです
あの人 仕事 彼が終わって
いわゆる退職して お寺のそばにいる人なんですけど
そんな暇はないんだと
僕は何があります？やっぱり今牛一匹買ったんだからといって
牛を餌を 1時間ごとに向こう別に餌あげる
あっちこっち縛っておくんですね
1時間ぐらい縛っておけばそこら辺食べちゃいますから
また他のところに縛っておくんです
牛の世はしなくちゃいけないんだ
ああそうですかと 僕はすぐその人出て行ったんだけど
もし私の頭にある考え方
その人に言ったならば
もうどうなるかと だから
いわゆるお寺に来て 説法を聞いて
ちょっとだけ修行でもして
そういういいことに活動に参加するということはできない
なぜならば暇がない 暇がないということは仕事がある
どういう仕事かというと
牛のお世話する仕事 じゃあその牛からその人は何か得るんですか？って
別に大したこと何もない
別に収入資源には全くならないんです
どうせ向こう仏教ですから
牛を肉のために売るわけは絶対しないし
そこでミルク出るわけでもないし
もうくだらないボロ牛でしたけど
やっぱりどこかに引っかかってるんですね
ですから そこはすごく大事なんです
もしその人に私は喋ったならば
自分のこの愚かさと人間でありながら
なんというおかしい 恥ずかしいことを考えて言ってるんですかと
分かったらそこでもう悟りの世界がいきなり生まれるんです
ある人がすごく瞑想するんです
そこで頭はすごくいいんです
そこで仏教の知識っていうのはもう抜群な知識があるんです
アビダンマの知識なんかそんなもんじゃなくて
すごいんです 瞑想もするんです
瞑想も結構ずっと進んでしまっちゃうんです
やっちゃったら でも悟りのところまではいかないんですね
で みんな驚くんですね
その精神的な この瞑想の世界で知ってることやら体験やら
いろんなことを聞いて
そこで本人も悟りのところまでいかないということを知っていて
こう言うんですね やっぱり私はダメなのはこの子供に
子供のことですよと それは子供の執着はそんな簡単には捨てられませんと言うんです
だから本人も知ってるんだから
もう救いようもないんです
牛の話した人にはもう全くバカだから一発言っちゃえばもうもう治る可能性あったんだけど
この本人は仏教の知っていて
瞑想の世界も知っていて
たまに私にもいろんなことをもう間違ったら忘れちゃったらすぐ教えてくれるぐらいの人で
女性の方なんですけど
自分の問題を知ってるんだから
だからどうしようもないんです
そこで子供のことじゃ
こんなもう私より 2倍倍ぐらい年上の女の女性が子供に対して何の執着ですかね
それで子供の子供一人がアメリカのどこかで大学教授をやっていて
もう一人はスリランカの大学でものすごく大教授で
もう一人ある会社でもすごい
もうもう堂々と立派に仕事をしていて
で 誰もないんですよ うちに
だから一人寂しくいるんです
子供たちはお母さんに自分の家に来てください
自分の家に来て 自分の家に来てくれと一生懸命頼んでるんです
子供たちにとっては自分一緒にいた方がもう面倒見やすいんだけど
でも自分にも内側的にいろいろ財産
土地があるんだから そこを置いておいていくわけにもいきません
言っちゃったら子供だから売ってしまっちゃうし
ですから それはどうかなと思って
でも子供には執着があるんですね
そこもまたすごいバカバカらしいですけど
そこに気が付かないんですね
自分が一人でいるんだから
もう子供はもうみんなもう立派に成長して
もう孫まで出てきて 孫も仕事をしているぐらいになっているし
それ誰一人も面倒見てあげなくちゃ大変だという誰一人もいないし
それなのに我が子に対する執着は捨てられないと思っているんですね
だからそこをものすごいバカバカらしいんだけど
自分の大事な精神の悟りをもう
かわいそうに 本当にすごい知恵があるんです
そのおばあさんの旦那さんっていうのは
もう すごいもう大変な人なんですね
いわゆる仏教に対する
旦那さんがお寺には向こうはあまり見たことはないんだけど
お寺には来ないんだけど
毎日もう家でもきちんと瞑想して
もうすごい高度な智慧があるんです
あった人なんです それにも似て
奥さんの方もみんないいんだけど
子供たちは別に仏教に対してはね
興味はないんだけど でもその子供たちに執着があってなかなか行かない
そういう風に我々は何かに引っかかってるんですね
そこで問題は その子供に引っかかってるわけでも
牛に引っかかってるわけでもないんです
[背景音楽]